it was a welcome sight for the
beleaguered canadian cruise industry
holland america's conning stamp cruised
under the lionsgate bridge and into the
port of vancouver early sunday the first
cruise ship to arrive in canada's
largest port since the pandemic started
more than two years ago it's vitally
important and i just want to acknowledge
how hard everyone has worked to make
today possible
about 1200 passengers and 900 crew were
on board in total 310 cruise ships are
expected to arrive in vancouver in 2022
with cruise ships making their way to
vancouver and other ports across canada
this season is
an exciting time for our travel and
tourism sectors in halifax the industry
resumes april 26 with a total of 152
vessels due to dock in the port of
halifax this year
nationwide cruising generates billions
of dollars and provides thousands of
jobs cruising in canada is an important
part of our tourism economy and prior to
the pandemic accounted for
30 000 jobs and contributed more than
four billion to
the canadian economy annually
canada lifted its pandemic-related ban
on cruise ships november first with
conditions
everyone on board must be fully
vaccinated and
passengers must test negative before
boarding
the conning stam had no confirmed covet
cases before arriving in canada we've
been working closely with transport
canada and other global health experts
as well as officials from this city and
port to make sure we're able to deliver
the cruise experience our guests are
looking forward to and one that is safe
early in the pandemic at least 40 cruise
ships suffered outbreaks before the
industry ground to a halt among the
worst the diamond princess more than 700
of the 3 700 passengers and crew on
board became infected while quarantined
in yokohama japan
14 deaths were connected to the outbreak
return of the cruise industry in canada
comes as some experts warn of a sixth
wave of the pandemic
clearly many passengers believe their
love of cruising outweighs any risks
catherine erkhardt global news vancouver